if you're a fan of city building than
the month of March certainly has the
game for you or at least I assume that's
what the hundreds of thousands of people
who bought city skylines on day one
would have to say cities skylines may
look an awful lot like ea's last still
City game but it seems like it's
certainly impressing a lot more people
than the latter did the city management
stimulator by paradox has sold 250,000
units in its first 24 hours of launch
which has set a new record for paradoxes
boxster selling game to date paradox
have congratulated the developer
colossal order who previously develops
these cities in motion games despite
taking obvious inspiration from simcity
2013 city skyline is a little different
from sin city in that it allows for more
comprehensive tinkering with the games
traffic energy and sewage systems among
other things in addition to that
skylines allows for offline play large
maps and player made mods and assets
which are already numbered in the
thousands on the game Steam Workshop
page let me know down in the comments if
you've tried out city skylines and what
you think of it so far as always we'll
be keeping you updated so stay tuned to
gamespot